[Music]  South cancer a freaky freaky dancer my  house got Robin be the what do they take  my grandma's silver did you call the  authorities  yeah the world is bigger than your  silverware Row one everyone is axel  taking my mind sometimes I feel like  going underneath a four-pole like I  can't even breathe the way people treat  each other makes me so furious Kevin  stop it is there anything I can do Open  Sesame  gotcha hey at least your son broke into  my house I have no idea where he is  vigilante actions a good way to get your  wig knocked off you have beautiful eyes  okay  what do you want for people to not be  [ __ ]  I'm not letting you shoot anyone anyone  anyone else I need the girl Bakura